这是我用AI做的母亲节广告, 全程没有视拍也不需要模特, 我是如何做到的呢, 先看整片
喂妈, 还没吃呢, 再加班, 嗯嗯, 来
爸爸, 为啥没拿来来给你蔬菜来
现在拉这儿还买不到蔬菜吗, 吃不完咋
来来早上五点过期来宰, 你就买不到
说了考好就给你, 肯定就给你, 跟你开个玩笑, 还生气了
喂, 外卖吗, 我没点外卖
肯定是别人给你点的, 电话地址都没错
喂妈, 我给你点的外卖收到了
我是说谁给我点的外卖, 你是怎么学会的
你留意给我发的视频照着学呗
一分钟教会你点外卖
最后一步最重要
你们工作忙, 之前让你自己做饭
妈现在觉得也不现实
在外面多注意身体, 准时吃饭
揭秘一下流程, 这是我制作的画布
大家可以看到我把剧情拆分成了四个板块
第一步我花了比后期制作还长的时间来做人物关系的设计
这一步是现阶在AI无法替代的
因为AI无法替代人类去感知真实生活
所有大家看到的角色都是我们身边的普通人
已经成家了中年男人
家教严厉的女高中生母亲
怀孕还在工作的准妈妈
加班的年轻人
在这里我的视觉用了柯达胶片质感
可以给你的图片也试试这个提示词
深途的时候我们仍然需要大量的抽卡和控制人物关系
讲故事一定是影视的核心
这意味着我们要做大量的取舍
比如这张图看着其实挺好看
但就不真实
因为现实生活中不可能在这种光鲜强度下
人物的面部还是清晰的
你不能为了追求画面清晰和清楚
而去要这张照片
所以我会重新调整提示词
人物关系变二广比变大
这些都是技巧记住了
所以出来的这张图反而更真实了
看不清人物面部又如何
我们要的是接近现实的这种拍摄效果
如法刨置我们有相同的方式去出完剩下的图
我们就进入了图生视频阶段
同时我们可以创造虚拟角色去控制视频的一致性
比如这个小女孩我就出了图片
我会在节点里面给图片进行关联
比如女孩站在这里
前景虚焦用这个女孩
虚拟角色创建和使用就会提高你影片的一致性
在图生视频的阶段
我们仍然有很多镜头会浪费掉
没关系一切也讲好故事为主
不要为了这个画面好看而动
导演最重要的
你其实是做取舍
最后我会根据影片的段落
去生成不同的背景音乐
这就根据你的设计来做
最后把所有的素材剪辑和制作到一起
这样一个视频就制作完了
流程还有很多细节
点赞高
我会继续给大家分享一些幕后的思路
我是罐头
我们下期节目再见